hello and welcome to PlayStation Grenade
2018 is a great time to be a PlayStation
gamer to be effective in count that a
warrior must not feel for his enemy
close your heart to their desperation
lose your heart to their suffering the
God of War series is set to continue
very soon with Kratos leaving the world
of Greek mythology behind and invading
our mythology with his son Atreus so I
thought now is a pretty good time to go
through everything we know about God of
War you ready let's do this
the story of Kratos will be continuing
from where we left off back in God of
War three so every single act of
violence in those previous three main
titles is canon including murdering your
own father or in my personal favorite
ripping off the head of heels
time has passed and although Kratos is
still mourning the loss of his wife and
daughter he now has a son Atreus who
will be accompanying his dad on this new
adventure and by the sounds of things
Atreus his mother may have either left
or have died
your mother's knife it belongs to you
now
from everything we've seen so far Atreus
will act similarly to Elly in the Last
of Us as both an assistance in battle
and also as the narrative core of the
story as Kratos teaches his son how to
hunt and ultimately push him to us being
his own Mallory Atreus is arrows can't
stun enemies giving his dad time to
close the gap and end the fight quickly
as Kratos builds combos he can order his
son to jump into leading to some
touching father-son moments you must be
a warrior from the outside looking in
it appears that whilst Kratos is
teaching his son how to be a total
badass
his son is teaching him the meaning of
humanity Trust and redemption but not
everyone is bad mother always said to be
open to those who can help
the story behind each god of war game
have always been compelling but this one
may hit you in the fields I'm not crying
it's I've just been cutting onions as I
mentioned at the start Kratos is leaving
behind Greek mythology and venturing
into a new world of Norse gods we've
already seen what looks to be the
mid-calf serpent your Mon gander I can't
say that sorry's Yaman gander young man
younger you try it as this is Norse
mythology could we see Kratos go up
against Thor the god of lightning and
maybe he's dad Odin Game Director Cory
bar log says the setting takes place
before the Viking era which would mean
far wouldn't be around is this a red
herring or maybe the Viking Norse gods
are being saved for future titles we'll
find out very soon oh and look a
freaking dragon flies overhead I cannot
wait for that battle the original God of
War combat was a hack-and-slash dream
with more weapons to use than you can
imagine
in the latest God of War title the
combat has been refined with a simple
shield and axe making up the bulk of
Kratos his attacks the shield falls
nicely away and the act can be caught
too Kratos when he raises his hand once
again reminiscent of Thor the fight
scenes we've witnessed so far show
Kratos using varied tactics to beat his
foes using his son to cause distractions
or finding environmental objects to sway
the fight in his favor
awesome this change in combat may be
jarring but don't worry Kratos has a
rage Bart bill which will allow him to
go on one of his legendary Spartan rages
and do things like this
going back to the Acts for a moment
which is named Leviathan this beast has
ruined lots for upgrades and attack
modifiers we've seen different elemental
damage types used with the ice and frost
ones the only extensive evidence we've
seen in-game which blend AoE attacks and
subtle slowing down of enemies using
freezing attacks this room slots on
Leviathan can change the properties of
the weapon both for light attacks and
heavy attacks let's quickly look at a
few things that have been confirmed but
we don't have any concrete specifics
just yet God of War will utilize a
crafting system the developers are
keeping very tight-lipped on this one
but it is suggested that items and
materials Kratos discovers on his
journey and picks up around the world
will grant us the ability to craft armor
sets Kratos will be venturing to some
pretty cold places so maybe a wolf pelt
over colt wouldn't go amiss as an
extension to the armour crafting game
director Corey bar log has confirmed
there will be new costumes to unlock
remember the all-black kratos with the
neon red markings and God of War II and
that was dumb epic and can only be
beaten by a pink version I won't hold my
breath on that one our crafting will
apply to Atreus 2 on our journey we will
be picking up XP to be used in a skill
tree for both Kratos and his son which
will be yet another RPG aspects of
progression to sit beside crafting and
the rune swapping in our axe the average
gamer will spend between 25 and 35 hours
trying to finish art of war and at
present there is no DLC or additional
content hinted at but if that does come
to fruition I'll be certain to make a
follow-up video on that and finally when
can we expect this juggernaut of a game
we're still waiting on an official date
but reddit has found the potential date
on the North American PlayStation
Network star March 22nd 2018 it may slip
another month but in the past March has
been used as a release window for other
god of war titles like always when the
date is confirmed I'll pin it in the
comments below so there you have it god
of war 2018 is shaping up to be a must
play title for PlayStation gamers
fingers crossed that the release date is
correct not long to wait now and
what's your appetite for future god of
war titles gory Balog has mentioned a
new direction for kratos which would see
him face off with Mayan and Egyptian
gods in future iterations kratos versus
a cyrus could be mind-blowing I'm Adam
from Playstation grenades it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time